if i had to do a pro con list um what
would you say
what is what are the good parts what are
the pros of where journalism is going
gen z i know i talk about them all the
time but that's like people born
basically after 1998 99
are so impactfully informed like me and
other millennials are watching
bridgerton and tuning out our lives like
antidepressants right
but they i mean look at the parkland
kids they they've experienced trauma in
similar ways to
folks in my generation but have
mobilized that trauma into a worldwide
movement greta thunder you know is this
crosses across
nations is that gen z folks are so
um energized and mobilized to consume
news and change politics
that i don't think the die off will
happen
they'll just change the mediums in which
people are engaging
and i think the less we pander to them
and the less we consent them
and the more we empower them to
either become content creators or
politicians or whatever right
um the more success we'll have with all
of this industry staying buoyant
welcome back to yang speaks this is zach
grauman
your host of the future of our limited
series that airs
every thursday today we are talking
about the future of journalism
and the one and only amazing britney
shepherd
is joining she was one of the youngest
white house correspondents
i believe ever and right now she's a
national politics reporter
for yahoo news and we talk about
how she got into this space how she
frankly rose so quickly but also how
this industry is evolving and how
journalism
is changing and if you are passionate
about journalism and our media
and where it is going this is the
episode
for you she covered us on the trail and
has that perspective from the
presidential as well
you don't want to miss this conversation
so britney shepard joining
to talk about the future of journalism
starting
right now
okay welcome back to yang speaks the
future of
we are joined today by a friend
and superstar i'm honored to be with you
because i i looked up to you
and really admired what you did as a pro
and as a person on the trails brittany
shepard joins
yang speaks what's up brittany good to
see you
great to see you virtually wish it was
in person wish it was in person
um excited to chat you let's let's start
with you
that's maybe a weird question how'd you
get into journalism like i feel like i
knew like one
friend in college in high school that
really want to be a journalist and i
feel like you probably grew up in a
world where lots of people around you
want me journalists but maybe i'm wrong
so tell me about you
it's funny that you say that because i
definitely did not want to be a
journalist surrounded by people who
definitely really
did so wind it all the way back i'm from
long island new york
uh i wanted to desperately leave new
york no offense to my parents they're
first generation immigrants i just love
them but it was time to fly the nest i
was applying to colleges and i just
didn't i didn't exactly want to know
know what i wanted to do because who
does when you're 18 who does when you're
21
but regardless i was like okay what can
i maybe make money in that's
communication based or on to do math
like uh
mass communication journalism maybe
that'll work
i mean i'd seen like goodnight and good
luck and generally knew
how basic newspapers were formed so i
applied a bunch of schools got into gw
here in dc and i went
kind of sight unseen assuming that i
would kind of figure out what i wanted
to do
along the way were you one of those kids
that knew
it sounds like maybe you're a
wishy-washy but like when you graduated
high school you had a direction
i kind of feel like i knew how i wanted
to make people feel
i either wanted to entertain or reach or
change the way people live their
everyday life and i was very open to the
ways and the mechanisms in which i could
do that
so whether that was entertainment or or
news or something in between
i i think i realized earlier that the
industries that existed then would not
exist in five years i didn't realize how
dramatic it would be and how many
layoffs it would cause in its wake
but i just knew that i had to have some
kind of north star or else i would get
lost
and the funny thing about college is you
could still be unemployed after and
that's what i was
when i graduated i was interning at
national geographic at the time
working on scripts i thought that's
where i was going to go i was going to
be a script supervisor and like work in
hollywood or new york and kind of touch
the industry in that way that didn't
work
that kind of then that industry
basically folded discovery left
dc that geo got bought by fox it was
lots of tumultuousness
and then i i couldn't stay in dc so i
went back home
and was a classic bum for a year out of
college
i think i applied to 150 jobs
in journalism and in that television
production company space
and i think i i got denied almost all of
i had a generally good gpa
i was involved in every club in the
world and i'm half black
like nothing was sticking um
i was like damn like no card is coming
out for me this time
and i i saw that there was a fellowship
for this frankie dink at the time little
startup in dc
called the independent journal review i
knew nothing about the company at the
time
but they were hiring someone just to
kind of write news copy or entertainment
copy it's like i could do that in my
sleep
i applied i got the job and two weeks
later i moved down to dc so that's kind
of how i got my original foothold
in journalism but it took me a long way
to get there first of all i know the
feeling in college i applied like i was
like it's gonna be a numbers game about
a hundred places
i'm gonna get eight interviews and one
offer like whatever it was
um and there were there was a large
period of time where the
the there was no there was no funnel
effect it was just 100 interviews
or 100 applications and zero anything um
my question is my parents said to me
when i was growing up they said zach
it's not about what you know sadly it's
about who you know
and good luck cause your mom and i no
nobody
um did it was that
uh was that part of the journey too like
seeing friends that were like less
qualified with a connection somewhere
starting to get jobs places
oh absolutely my parents are the exact
same thing to me but in a british accent
that's literally the only difference
yeah they didn't go to college they
knew no one in the industry inside of
the industry they were living a happy
life on long island
yet when i went to gw there were tons of
connected people very very wealthy
people
from other countries who just had
footholds they were generational
journalists like grandsons so i didn't
even realize that was a thing
i think it was ignorant of me to not
realize that legacy wasn't just about
college admission it was also in
getting a foothold in your career oh it
was totally frustrating because i
thought i had everything i was the full
package on paper
and i was getting kicked around on it
from porch to porch to porch
and i i realized that there was no space
for me in the entry level
in legacy news so traditional newspaper
network unless i wanted to i don't know
if we can curse but eat
dirt for a while make no money and feel
like i'm being lapped which is something
that i deal with
i feel like i deal with emotionally now
even though i'm i feel like i'm in a
good place
so right i felt like i had nowhere to
turn to except for startups and i'm
actually i'm so glad i did because that
was able to skyrocket me to a place
where i think
i'm 26 now but at the time i was 21
22. and because the white house
correspondent and the company had worked
working out had to get hired out or left
or something
i had gone to lunch with my boss at the
time who was it was definitely a tech
company that was just producing content
let me be clear
right and my boss was definitely silicon
valley minded which that's a whole other
conversation but
that's what i wanted to do i think i
said i wanted to be maybe a tech
reporter one day or a space because he's
working at geo
and i had gotten back to my desk and i
basically got the offer to be the white
house correspondent
sight unseen at 21 22
and then two weeks later that was my
first political news job with no bylines
no like job experience
and that would not happen that would not
happen in the washington post right
what was the name of this startup
independent journal review okay
i don't i don't know if it actually
exists anymore or at least in the form
it used to
let's think about startups right you get
a bunch of vc money and it either works
and for the most part it doesn't
but it was able it launched a lot of
people's careers you got a great title
and probably a great job and i was a
little [ __ ] kid you know and i mean
i was 22
with white house correspondents in the
briefing room who have been there for
decades and decades and decades and
decades and that was the best thing that
i could ever do
is trial by fire during the trump
administration at no other white house
do i think it would have been given the
leash that i was given and the ability
to just talk to anyone in the room
because a lot of the journalists were
either fed up or they had emotional they
had a point of view they had something
to prove or something to say
during that time for i think very
justifiable reasons
so they had no problem shooting straight
from the hip and telling me how it was
and they also didn't feel threatened by
me like i wasn't competition
so that i could learn very earnestly and
then i tried to do my best you know
climb the ladder as fast as i could
and that's how i landed in political
journalism it's kind of a weird windy
story but
now i i've ping-ponged around but
eventually i'm stuck here in dc at least
for a little while now
yeah i really i knew you were young you
realize you're that young i'm just
jaw-dropping you more so brittany um
i'm so curious with this and you kind of
touched on it but i want to dive in a
little more it's like
who's going into journalism right like
what because it is
andrew talks about a lot it's a it's in
some ways a dying industry in some ways
a growing industry depending on where
you're looking at
um in terms of how we're getting news we
can talk about a lot but it's
it's definitely changing and the pay
is also getting more bifurcated
depending on your entry level and that
sort of thing and you said
first like i'm coming in with the same
title as people have been there for 30
years
um now luckily for you as a startup so
it was it was less intimidating but i'm
sure
some competitors had really young people
in some of these roles as well
um so who gets into this and
maybe even why yeah there are a lot of
different sims variations of journalists
is that's kind of how i see like if
you're a video game starting character
lots of different kinds of people who
could be a journalist
a company similar to ours at the time
was axios and they had lots of younger
people who actually went to college with
who are still killing the game who i
love very deeply
and i think folks who were going into
the startup space
were people who kind of wanted to
reinvent the wheel i think kind of the
og jonah peretti
buzzfeed buzzfeed minded people who saw
that there's something that wasn't
clicking in the industry
either and how they were consuming news
or they they were disenfranchised by and
just enchanted by it and they wanted to
change so kind of like creative minded
folks
where they cared about writing and about
news copy but they wanted to make uh you
know move fast and break things that's
not what they say in silicon valley
right
it was like that was the centralizing
motivation i think that i might fall
under that bucket a little bit
then there's the folks who when they
were 9 and 10 years old had been reading
the wall street journal because that's
all they know when they're from
connecticut no offense to connecticut
right
i'm from connecticut and you should give
it all of the [ __ ] it deserves
as a long islander i'll say it where
it's generational either their family
works in business or their family
is in the industry because there are
many people who their grandfather their
grandmother worked in publishing and
then
and then it trickles down right so there
were those people who are like hardened
by the ap
style book and they work at wires and
they work at papers and they're
wonderful journalists but their demeanor
and their approach
is very different they believe in mass
objectivity
again this is a big push pulled in the
industry itself even with within my age
group and i think it translates as you
go up and up and up to the vets
um and then you have people who are just
rich and that can cross through
everything you know and i came from a
comfortable upbringing i'm very
self-aware of that it's very difficult
to be working class
and be an entry-level journalist at
least in washington dc or in
a kind of national journalist role
because if you squeeze in and look at
the papers like your little neighborhood
paper
they probably pay their writers minimum
wage
if you are a college student with loans
you can barely afford your own health
care maybe your family can barely afford
them on health care
you don't have time to piddle making
like little you know
articles for 15 bucks i mean it's a huge
issue
so then that may have a pipeline problem
where it's only folks from ivy league
colleges
and gw right who are wealthy
so you end up getting predominantly i
think
classist or reporters who have no
ability to sympathize or empathize with
any other class structure
and predominantly white um they're not
mutually exclusive
and i think that it's a problem in
newsrooms but to answer your question i
think that's the general archetype of
people
who want to go in and i think sprinkled
among them are like bleeding heart
people
right who like want to save the world
and they want to bring
truth to power ideally a newsroom has
all of them
but i think those are the kind of folks
who who at least start
right so this is this is the crux of it
i'm so
i'm so so fascinated by this and i
feel like you've seen enough of all of
the world so give a fun perspective on
it because i'm excited to talk to you um
let's talk about journalism today and i
want to be curious about pros and cons
and i think it's really easy
i'm guilty of this and don't feel bad
about it like
i'm [ __ ] on the media all the time
um and there's tons of criticism and i'd
like to bucket those out too but
i think the media does some things
really well today um i do think there
are some either positive trends or
so i wanted to give credence to like the
good stuff too so let's talk a journal
today
if i had to do a pro con list um what
would you say
what is what are the good parts what are
the pros of where journalism's going
today i have thoughts too but i feel
like you should start
i think from it selfishly from a
newsroom perspective i think we're
the most diverse we've ever been we have
a long way to go
but because of that we're able to cover
stories with nuance whether whether it's
race or
gender or any kind of intersectional cut
class very well
look what's happening right now with the
shogun trial during the
floyd protests over the summer how that
intersected into the election
i i at least saw more folks on
television more folks and print by
lines who were unafraid to be
themselves i i always give journalists a
shout out he's my friend wes
lowry formerly of the washington post
now of cbs 60 minutes
he's only a few years older than me has
a pulitzer
black and he kind of very famously left
the post
being very very outspoken on twitter
about
the racial inequities within that
newsroom and with within news
and that empowered a lot of us to do
similar things online
and being able to and this is maybe like
a 1a
use all of that on social media to take
away
some of the opacity between
our sources our readers our process
and us as personalities that is i think
tantamount to growing media trust and i
think something that we do
very well now of course there's tons of
space to grow
but i don't think you talked to
journalists 10 years ago about now
who would ever think that we'd have the
leash to be able to say the things we do
that's a good one i i the one
one of the things i said doing realized
i said transparency in a weird way i
think there's things that are not
transparent but
i think reports of what's going on in
the new york times newsroom in
washington post newsroom or how people
are writing stories or
like twitter in a weird way can be
really raw and really personal
because it's it's the personality
the tweeter and the tweet right there
[ __ ] like theoret besides our
politicians i get people to review their
tweets
it's usually the human um and i think
that's cool you get to know the
reporters
um so that is
to me at least in the long run a good
thing
right because it's transparent there's
no like backroom
um editorial process as much as there
used to be i'm sure there are and
that's the thing um the other one i had
was that it's
the the 24 7 aspect i think it drives
people nuts but that is theoretically a
good thing where you're always there but
the biggest one is like it's never been
easier to report like anyone who's made
bad for some bigger behemoths but
anyone can hop on a camera and live
stream and be a reporter i don't know
your thoughts on that but that feels
like
generically generally positive i have
a lot of mixed thoughts about it i call
it the ratatouille problem that anyone
can be a chef
thing because all right i believe in the
democratization
of of the media process of becoming a
journalist i think the barrier to entry
should be way
low but with that power
becomes lots of responsibility and if
you do not have the training or at least
people around you
you can either misuse it on purpose or
by accident which we've seen a lot of in
the last four to
eight years people and this is not
citizen journalism right this is not
folks during an insurrection or an
uprising going to twitter and recording
and getting information out there
that helps us tell the story that is
valuable i mean that changes the
politics and democracies of certain
countries
i want to like flag that as separate but
i think people
joe and jill on the street who then
start their own news blog which again
can have lots of important news value
but
they can use that without the proper
training or resources or
fact checking knowledge and spread
disinformation
i hate this term fake news which
incorrect information in which it
proliferates because it's so easy to go
viral with the right headline with the
right packaging
they could stumble on it by accident uh
and then now there's a mess on our hands
of how do we untangle this
um there was this column in the
washington post last week and there was
this little fact i want to cite
that since the 1970s
trust in the news has fallen 70 70 to
40.
that's huge social media making it more
democratized
has impacted it by a little bit when we
talk about the cons that's where my
biggest
con is i think i love that you said that
because some of these pros and cons it's
like they're all
most of them are double-edged swords
right like 24-hour news
exciting you can always get anything
same times like do we ever take a break
no
driving anybody nuts um youtube's
algorithm
facebook's algorithm as of now doesn't
really
care if you're the washington post
versus xyz q and on
weekly podcast if people are clicking on
it if people are interested and excited
about it
or just like find the you know if it's
just click bait it's still going to get
um a lot of views and interest and
excitement and that is the big challenge
all right want to talk to you guys about
better help which is our sponsor on yang
speaks
i think most people lost their mind
during covid i personally did
and one of my i call it my steam valve
is my better help time once a week so i
meet with my counselor
basically just helps me blow off steam
in a really healthy way i just talk
about things i never
talk about and it's great and it's
needed right now
just say hey what the heck is happening
in the world and talk about what we're
all going through what you personally
are going through whether it's
depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma anger
grief self-esteem you name it for me
it's helping focus my ambition
and understand how i react to certain
things in the world
it's awesome i love it i look forward to
it every week so here's the deal
i want you to start living a happier
life today i want you to check out
better help and as a listener you're
going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
join over one million people have taken
charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp help dot com
slash yang
in the past if you wrote a column you
wrote a front page headline tons of
research
you put it out you write it it's put on
paper
and the paper boy which i was one they
just delivered it
they didn't comment on it and now you
have
college educated editors and
reporters writing articles but the
distribution the paper boys
paper boys and girls won't call it um
are now college educated social media
experts and engineers that took the same
history classes and philosophy classes
at elite universities and so they have a
say
and so they don't like it they're either
going to complain about it or put up a
fight
or that sort of thing which to me flips
the editorial process on its head
because not only have you like
researched something decided to put it
out you have to get it through like a
defense
wall just to not have mutiny in your own
company
um thoughts on that like have you seen
it at yahoo you see
elsewhere are we allowed to talk about
that i think yahoo is different because
it we are a company that's not just a
company providing news
we are a search engine that also has
entertainment vertical people use the
yahoo sports for fantasy betting and
now who finance for stock so we are just
a portion of a larger
tech company with a different kind of
vision i'll never forget
one of the first like real like traffic
bumps for us in this campaign was
a piece on casually that cnbc did but it
got repurposed on
msn i believe which is a website i think
yahoo owns or did at the time 2018.
msn stuff is now on our home page yeah
you haven't been on amazon in a very
long time and that's the aol
older demographic and they loved it it
was great so thank you yahoo
for that i'll pass it along to the chef
um
but i it's interesting to talk about the
paperboy problem because it's not
just um the folks uh
programming the social media apparatuses
in which we're tweeting out these
stories
it's actually other journalists too and
if a bunch of powerful journalists
don't like your story you cannot punch
up
and vice versa so there's incense
there's so many different incentives
here incentives to
network and befriended these like four
or five or ten very popular online
journalists because they tweet your
story
you're well respected like if maggie
haberman tweets must read
and links to your story even if it's a
bad story and i'm sure she wouldn't
i don't know her personally but let's
just put that a b test out there
the clamor around it would probably be
exceedingly positive even if the story
is just a neutral story
versus if she says it's a bad story then
the pylon can be larger i think it's
something that we think about in other
communities too right
it's always about having knowing where
you fit ethically
in in the latter and yeah it worries me
because then people end up chasing clout
for lack of a better term
than pursuing the truth but on the flip
side
people are held more accountable now
than they ever were before
so joe blow racist can't go on the new
york times and say like
i think why to the superior race what do
you think
as a thought exercise and realize that
his world words also have equal real
life implications
that's the key right there that is the
key and it's like
it's frustrating and amazing to me
because the one thing i said was pros
like you can't get anything past
anybody today right there are so many
frankly so many critics um or
the other side of the story to get by
all the time which i think is
awesome like that's great right however
there is i think there is value in
dissenting opinions and i this is my
opinion but i also think it's borne out
in the facts of how many people
supported donald trump
where you have news outlets that
typically skew left
the press normally skews left
historically are not covering
why millions 78 million people are
voting for donald trump
in a responsible way with a point where
those people are
those people the people voting for many
times are just like well i'm just not
going to read this anymore because
they're not even bothering to understand
why i would find this person appealing
um
now don't get me wrong that's not a
that's not
like supporting of donald trump's
policies or anything like that but it's
there is i think some of our papers used
to be like hey
here's one side here's the other side we
put it out there we agree to disagree
and your point is also well some of
those
alternative sides are [ __ ] up or
they're racist or they're dark
and we don't want to do that and where
is the line
i think that's such an interesting point
i'm glad you brought up the
people not covering the 73 million
people who voted for trump with
compassion because this was the other
con something i wanted to bring up if we
didn't get to it
which is the role of ethics in
journalism because i would say
10 15 50 years ago folks didn't care
there was no ethics it was here's the
wire here's the who what when where why
deal with it there is no conclusion
drawn it was not this is bad this is
good
there's a party happening at the
landmark theater this week
or the mayor did this and passed why
bill
but because of the advent of social
media there becomes a what is our ethnic
responsibility and i'm sure that you've
talked about this person before but
i've been listening to a hundred million
tristan harris podcast so
tristan is a yang speaks guest yeah
great guy
someone i find endlessly fascinating who
i want to replicate in
to every single newsroom for folks who
don't know he was
ethical design ethicist at google very
famously left because he
he couldn't find a way to justify what
these big tech companies were doing
because they weren't operating in a way
that was
um ethical to the human population like
people were killing themselves on social
media you
any any kind of big deal social media
that existed
was true and i believe that the press
also plays a role because we're
we're not just publishing things with
impunity anymore and i believe there's a
big secret journalism who will disagree
with me
who says we are the fourth estate and we
exist to
tell stories of people who are a voice
to the voiceless or the facts of the
matter and then we step back and let the
world
fight it out i disagree because the way
in which we frame
information both in headline in body
our point of view isn't everything we
write unless you work for a newswire and
that's just
physically impossible with the amount of
inches you have influences
how people process the news and there
was a he was on another podcast talking
about the information gap
and it's not that you and i get the same
story and we have two different opinions
is that
you see one version of the story and i
see something completely different
because social networks
have tinkered their algorithms that you
and i see completely separate versions
of the same narrative
so it's more and more division because
we're just getting deeper and deeper and
deeper and deeper
into a version of the truth that
confirms whatever we think because
that's how social media makes money
we as journalists who are digital native
and i would say i'm digital native i've
only been born
knowing computers and phones and
typewriters and palm pilots and all of
those things
we know where our stories are landing
and how we are landing this is not some
kind of hidden
theory and these folks talking about it
now they didn't like just
take it out of the vault and be like
look at all the bad things that we're
doing with social media
they're just whistleblowers right if we
don't think about how our stories land
and how we can change them
to reach a trump voter
and abide in voter in a similar way so
that that
information gap gets smaller and smaller
and smaller
i think we are doing a disservice i'm
not saying
because of us folks died on january 6th
but i'm not not saying that our rhetoric
has nothing to do with it
if we do not think about the ethics of
journalism or the ethics of how we're
even transporting the news on social
media which is how
[ __ ] some of these companies make their
money right on social media ads and
proliferation and home page views and
and the like
we know if folks are getting angry
because angry clicks
also drive home page views and then
folks get super angry
and and they're armed with incorrect
information and then they start storming
cities
yeah they i mean you can literally a b c
d
tests which for those of you we've said
that term a lot but it's you can try one
headline and try another basically write
five headlines
throw them all out there and the
algorithm will find the ones that more
people are clicking and keep those and
get rid of the ones that don't work
and we used to do that you know at the
start of i worked out we did it all the
time on facebook like it was a way of
making
money and folks would get more angry and
we would be
we would be doing that on purpose
because that's how we'd get more traffic
to get more money
and that's an ethics problem that
one journalist alone cannot conquer but
newsrooms together
can
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by athletic
greens i freaking love this stuff i
literally just took some
athletic greens it's this wonderful
magical green powder you can get a big
like
container of it or you can get a little
mini pouches for traveling and you scoop
it or you open the pouch put it in some
water mix it up
drink it it tastes great one tasty scoop
of athletic greens contains 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more
they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet and give
you a little energy which i love and
focus
and also aids with digestion and
supports a healthy immune system
all without the need to take multiple
vitamins and crap like that so it's very
cool very efficient and very tasty
and plus right now our audience is
getting a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
so here's the deal visit
athleticgreens.com
yang so join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world
who are making a daily commitment to
getting their health better
every day so again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs a
day
do it
so i'm gonna possibly
uh weighed into contentious waters here
but
i'm so curious i'm like applying this to
a real world example and
the one to me that just happened that i
think is so interesting
fascinating is the the new georgia
voting law
so and hear me out now don't be wrong
while i'm at the camp is we should be
letting everybody vote as much as
possible if we believe in democracy that
should be the baseline right so
um now but i'm so curious with your
thoughts on
narratives here um and like finding the
objective truth and does an objective
truth even exist
it's at a certain point um so the left
this law comes out in georgia um
which we can talk about detail the left
is literally screaming
to hella high water like joe biden
himself is saying this is jim crow era
uh suppression of black voters um
you've got the state of georgia
boycotting the the major league baseball
all-star game you've got i think today
which is april 20th happy 420 yen gang
uh
home depot is potentially being
barricaded you got coca-cola these big
base in atlanta these corporations are
waiting in and the left is like this
is toxic this is the worst thing in the
world and the right
is saying um you're ridiculous
we've made a ton of concessions on both
them now i've read the law
and i agree they are stifling some
access which is dark and screwed up
um and in a good area in some areas a
lot of access
um but i do think the wright did make
concessions on this law like i think
they never had um like they've expanded
early voting
in rural communities there were no laws
on the books so they had early voting
for six months which is a
long time i hate long-term elections so
they cut that to three which sound like
cutting in half sounds terrible but
having a three month
early voting period is a long in new
york city it's
three six three to four weeks so that's
a long time i think the
the only time they're acquiring ids is
if you're voting absentee and even so
you can get around it with
everything like literally not everything
but you don't even need a social
security number to get one now it's a
pain in the ass it's more barriers so
that's where the left's saying but my
point was
it felt like a a further left narrative
than maybe was
um possibly the truth not that the law
wasn't dark not that these companies
shouldn't know what they've done but
like
it felt like we just went bang polarized
here we are
as am i is am i missing something is
this a narrative's problem
is it a nope this is actually [ __ ] up
zach shut the hell up like like what is
um and i feel like it's a good example
especially when it's racially charged
of how the left and right process the
facts
you know i don't know if it's my place
to open on the actual legislation
right but i think it's important here to
point out that news doesn't exist in a
vacuum
right it doesn't like one thing happens
in one part of the timeline and this
happens in that part of timeline
people's attitudes and angers evolve and
stack i think a lot of where this
narrative comes in
is because folks were so angry about um
the big lie essentially trump coming out
and saying
that all these votes were stolen and
your listeners i think know the story by
now
so there is mass anger among democrats
that this process is being disputed
um because they believe actual people
are disenfranchised by
gerrymandering their states oh and the
people who suffer whenever they make
voting harder the people who
the people get left off whenever they
make voting harder are people of color
is by the numbers um and so there that
is why this point matters
and why or for me i lie on the left but
i don't love
the divisiveness that comes from this
even if it's accurate
um it just doesn't see i don't know i'm
just more curious on like how the media
fuels this or if they don't it's just us
just us being idiots
i think everyone's a part of it the
reason i talked about um
the big lie is because i i think the jim
crow
language i'm sure obama thinks that
separately
but it's also a product of anger
mounting over a long period of time
and that's context and that's where we
come in
because if you see a headline that says
um biden says georgia id law is or
georgia id law is new jim crow
there's some context missing there but
it's also important to realize
television radio print and digital
all serve very different audiences and
very different gods right
television god is i have three minutes
we have a sales commercial in the middle
we want to have really interesting
panels and if they're not journalist
panels they're
reactionary panels and do you know what
goes viral on twitter it's not
peaceful conversations uh that are full
of nuance
at least not on my feed zach like
journalists are they're still businesses
so that's what fuels them and so that's
where that comes in
folks who watch a lot of tv are going to
see that and if they disagree
get super pissed off be like i can't
believe they're exaggerating this
narrative and they might be
but that's where that reaction comes
from folks who probably diversify their
news appetite
probably are reading more about the
nuance but
the caveat that's that people have jobs
to do and things to work
and people don't read people to listen
to the news people don't read the news
so that this very simple narrative gets
amplified and amplified and amplified
and people get angrier and angrier and
angry and angrier
where just feeling yourself with
information can probably make it
a lot more civil of a conversation but i
i think without opining too much about
politics and say to where we are in the
world
we don't make it easy for nuanced
convert and we being the media do not
make it easy for nuanced conversations
to happen
on social media or otherwise um
because our new ad incentives are to
make things as
splashy and as controversial as possible
because our industry is dying and we
also need jobs so it's like
how do you untangle that headphone cord
i i don't think that i figured it out
yet
and i guess my brother points like this
a lot of these issues are really
important
conversations we have to have as opposed
to
black or white opinions that people
right now are having like well the only
way we're going to
ever if we disagree with the georgia law
which i do
we need to talk about it again in a way
that we can
like prevent other states from doing it
and ideally change it right and i think
both our own world and how the media
plays in it kind of
can prevent that or um or excite that on
either side
let me ask you this um so we had tim
alberta on
his podcast recently from politico or
now i'm at the atlantic and um
and carly riley our finance director was
on and she said something like i always
wanted a uh
like a grade a b certification on
journalists or articles
and the other idea that i was thinking i
was like and you said maybe a journalist
shouldn't have to go get a degree but i
was always curious like could
the way you go to med school or law
school or hell
being a hairdresser a stylist school
like is there something where all
journalists can be like well like
this is the bar for um our quality
this is an interesting conversation that
i used to have in college all the time
um and i think my gut reaction is
i don't want to carry journalist papers
because
it's easy for me to get it because i
went to a very good accredited four-year
um university but there are folks who
didn't finish college who are in
newsrooms now
who have stacks of pulitzers like where
and i don't have a pulitzer so do i not
carry the paper
my question for all of these kind of
certifications is who sets the bar
for cosmetology school there is a set of
things you need to know
are you going to kill someone with this
bleach do you know how to handle
scissors
there are very basic tenets of being a
hairdresser that is regulated on state
level
there's no state or federal regulation
for journalism because that couldn't
exist because then it's like someone has
the power
to regulate free speech in the way that
we think of certification for
for meat there's no journalist fda
because if it is who would we appoint
and why and those are human beings with
agendas who can be influenced by the
news
it's just a part of our society that
doesn't exist in that in that
way um i think
it's it's difficult like you were just
saying before that it's
these conversations aren't happening but
look at the rise of podcasts now
like every six white guys you know have
a podcast this white guy does yeah
exactly well and you know and and many
other people like
the rise of npr's i feel like having a
moment right now and
um you know we have michael barbaro on
the daily
people like on tinder and bumble are
talking about how much they love
podcasting i think that radio and
long-form format is having a moment
because there
is a hunger to have complicated
conversations so that's just like
i don't think all hope is lost and
i think unfortunately to this question
you have to be the only
certifier of your own news unfortunately
that is the responsibility of a human
being it falls on them
um and that's difficult
because there are people with different
capacities to process the truth
that's just the way the cookie crumbles
and that's difficult i think for
me to metabolize see we talk about lack
of institutional trust andrew and i talk
about that all the time
and media is the one that hits society i
think the hardest or one of the hardest
um medicine would be the hardest i think
which we're learning in covid
um but people now trust people they
don't trust institutions right people
trust britney shepherd more than they
trust yahoo no offense yahoo it doesn't
matter where you work they trust you
more
um the so let me ask you this let's
start i
want to talk about where it's going my
first question for you is um
if you're comfortable sharing like what
are your incentives now
at yahoo or maybe generally like what
are you
what are they what does your the boss or
the powers that be tell you
that your priorities should be and then
so one is priorities and two if you do
well on certain things do you get paid
more um
you know and financially incentivizes
certain things too they answer your
first question what's my incentive
getting paid
i always wanted to say that because i
think a lot of journalists are a little
gun shy to be like you know
there's lots of bleeding hearts out
there we all want to make money and i
just think it's important to be
transparent
um depends where you work about the
article pay scale thing personally i
have a salary
i have an expectation to publish
regularly
what that means depends a lot on what's
happening in the news cycle
um it depends a lot about what's
happening per day
that crosses differently per institution
if you work at a place
well formerly folks like business
insider in places that was like really
heavy content-wise
those folks probably published four or
six times a day at igr there were times
where i had to publish
six articles a day or else because
that was their money-making model was
flood the zone
and it worked well until it did right um
so at least for me when i'm thinking of
okay i wake up i read the news i reflect
on the news from last night where do i
go from here
um i try to you know maybe bang out
three stories
a week but i also have other
responsibilities like going into the
white house pooling yada yada making
calls
um trying to break news keeping up my
social media but
i i think that my personal incentive i
think my
bosses would be happy if i got a story
that was interesting
scoopy so you know with information that
hasn't been out before
and attracts a lot of homepage traffic
that last bit i think is the most
important for the c-suite people
where i work because i work at tech
company and they're they're all about
bottom lines
i get it that's how they make money
that's why they run a very successful
cell phone company
right verizon owns yahoo and it is very
difficult sometimes to marry
all of those interests because some
things that i'm very much interested in
like
space force policy or talking about ubi
or writing features is not like
splashing next to a miley cyrus sideboob
compilation on the home page
just being real so how do i balance the
needs of my bosses with mine
i don't know i'm still figuring that out
and i think a lot of us are
too some people just go ah i'll deal
with my passions privately
and just what's the day turn story biden
sign this today this happened on the
hill today go go go go go
and that works for some people that
doesn't sustain me and i think would
cause burnout which we're seeing a lot
of in the industry
um but at the end of the day
if our c-suite people up in new york who
work for verizon
say we don't want yahoo news anymore
because they're not providing enough
content to the home page we're not
bringing
enough percentage of money to our bottom
line we're gone
and that's why i think you see a lot of
less
nuanced journalism or click bait or
whatever you want to call it
because there's a fury because we don't
have monster monetization
like payball right and that's where
that's for the other side of this coin
is then you set up a paywall
and you can kind of like the atlantic
and you can do whatever you want and you
could be tim alberta and you can write
beautiful beautiful features because
people are paying in a premium and
you're owned by a billionaire
yep and this is the biggest challenge
because
you have certain companies like business
insider buzzfeed or the
you know it depends where you are i
guess business desire is changing a bit
with their paywall but
um certain companies like we are
clickbait we're here to make money we
don't care
get the clicks and there's a certain
amount of respect i have and that
they're
honest with themselves and they're you
know it's like i do i do then you have
others that are like we're behind the
paywall we're gonna write great content
but you have to pay for it you have to
pay premium and then pr
that price probably gonna go up over
time uh deal with it
and then you have others that i think
are stuck in
like in a really difficult challenge and
it's probably where you sounds like you
guys are at yahoo where it's
i have great journalists like yourself
they can write great content
they also need to write great content
that a lot of people care about
and as much as i love reading about
um what the new york times said an
article on
the difference between like flourishing
and depression is something called
languishing and what we're
like which is a fascinating article
today um
i also love reading about whatever
scandal of the day happened or whatever
car crash news they get me on it's the
same way everybody does um what's
happening with
you know matt gates in florida whatever
the heck he's doing
um so
to me that's the eternal challenge um
thoughts on where that goes and i'd love
your thoughts on sub stack too where a
lot of
sadly only your your more established
journalists are really able to do this
and make money but they're
they're just like look i don't want to
fight these battles anymore i'm just
going to write whatever i want and
there's a platform substance where
people can or patreon wherever any user
people can pay me whatever they feel is
valuable and they have a big enough
platform that it doesn't matter they
make a ton of money
um thoughts on
the end game here um over the next five
ten years
well i think you can hit the nail on the
head here
i think folks for this kid fed the [ __ ]
up and they're going to leave
institutional journalism to go on their
own because they can
um journalism for better or for worse
has become a personality game
you might know who chris eliza is you
might not know one thing he published
but you know that you either really like
him or you really don't like him these
people
have legions of fans
like as much as you know as much as
andrew does much as biden does but just
maybe not aoc i think she's the
perfect example of influencer politician
right and there's also influencer of
journalists on the rise
and it makes people buku bucks they
leave their newsroom
they either go to sub stack or patreon
or they become a twitch streamer
or they do multi-platform on youtube and
become a partner
or they become a tick tock news
influencer and then they go to south by
southwest and get speaking fees and they
get signed by an
agency and they make triple the amount
of money they could
doing traditional news because
they can't they get all these projects
they go to politicon and they
feel both personally um
sustained and monetarily sustained
their i think is diminishing returns
because not everyone can be a celebrity
we're seeing that now it doesn't
it flames out very quickly and as far as
you go up other
journalists would love to punch you down
and see you fall and have your career
go up in flames right so
this makes for a very volatile future of
the industry i think that you'll always
have
the grey lady like you're always going
to have the new york times because
nostalgia sells so much money
and there will be like the entire upper
west side will go
and start rioting if the new york times
folds right
um there's institutional buying for the
new yorker as well let's say the la
times
but for not like folks like the miami
hero like that's gone
um so you'll always have that
but i think more and more you'll you'll
see individually
brand journalists as brands they have
their own books and podcasts and
whatever
i don't think that's inherently bad but
i think it intrinsically changes the way
people
contact news and that worries me because
people are barely reading the news now
and if they don't like that personality
if the if people who like me now stop
liking me
then they're not going to engage with
the news anymore and then we're going to
have completely uninformed public
the idea of people reading less news or
engaging with less news
than now makes me very sad um
so that's but that that's where i can
see it going um
in a negative way but in a nutshell i
wanna i want to have a positive
interpretation here gen z i know i talk
about them all the time
but that's like people born basically
after 1998 99
are so impactfully informed like me and
other millennials watching
bridgerton and tuning out our lives like
antidepressants right
but they i mean look at the parkland
kids they they've experienced trauma in
similar ways to
folks in my generation but have
mobilized that trauma into a worldwide
movement greta thundberg you know is
this crosses across
nations is that gen z folks are so
um energized and mobilized to consume
news and change
politics that i don't think the
die off will happen they'll just change
the
mediums in which people are engaging and
i think the less we pander to them and
the less we consent them
and the more we empower them to
either become content creators or
politicians or whatever right
um the more success we'll have with all
of these industries staying bullied
it's so interesting where so we said
earlier like people trust
people they're stopped in the trust
institutions but the gen z
especially as they get older i'm curious
i think they're
there are institutions they do trust um
they're just different i think they
trust tic toc in a weird way they are
living in a completely different world
that even you and i are living in
um but compared to our parents and
grandparents um
it might as well be mars it's probably
actually pluto um
and i agree with you like the rise of
personalities and fall of personalities
will probably be the future of
journalism
andrew talks about um he's like the way
i see
it going right now is you have we
completely don't do anything which is
the path we're on
and it's just this wild west of
disinformation
and you end up having really terrible
people
win political races because
even if the correct information's out
there either people aren't getting it or
don't want to get it right
um which i think has happened um and the
other easy the other model or you do
he says or you do what they've done in
um in england or the uk or like with the
bbc or they have some sort of
state-sponsored
network that is overseen by a bipartisan
board and that sort of thing which to me
sounds great but also sounds dangerous
in that if you have a
true like authoritarian person get in
charge that's the first thing they
probably take over
thoughts on but andrew's point is you
can't do
nothing like doing nothing is what's
happening right now and that's a
disaster so
uh from i know you're passionate about
policy
thoughts on what you actually could do
as a government federal state or local
um my my other thought is fund
philanthropically
501 c3 style but maybe funded for the
federal government local journalism all
over the country
that was my answer give local
journalists more
money the the best reporting i see come
out of minneapolis is from the star
tribune
right these people know local
journalists know their communities and
communities trust like
people from down the street they're not
going to trust people from washington dc
nor should they frankly uh and
that is a way it's never ever going to
be
top down for news it never was walter
cronkite didn't
bust the door open in dc was here i am
here's a news institution no folks
hustle
from the lowest parts of their lowest
the most local parts of community
up and some folks never want to leave
because that's their passion
i truly think if when we try to do that
in the whc and the white house
correspondents association there is a
small amount of i would say sorry a
large amount of money that doesn't go to
the dinner
that goes to scholarships of folks in
local communities for them to either
come to dc or you know pump up their own
careers
wherever they are that is the most
important thing and the way that you can
you can teach someone to fish without
giving them the fishing rod instead it's
owned by the united states government
or you can take it away at any time and
then they're going to starve again
uh you know uh but you have to convince
a lot of people that it's worth giving
money local journalism
because some folks are so disenchanted
with news that they just don't
read and they don't care that's the
challenge but i think that there's a
very clear solution
i think it is too it is expensive but
you know it's also expensive
uh society's disintegration and the
failing of all your systems
and yeah george expensive creating
algorithms on social media
that force users to stay on the app
longer and longer and longer and longer
and longer so that they're
less and less informed let me ask you
this as we was rapper he's like
where does someone like you get their
news
someone who's like passionate news and
reading all the time what are you
allowed to reveal your sources there
surprisingly i'll give you my my morning
routine
like an influencer i wake up and i look
at tick tock for about half an
hour and i actually see what's on the
minds of the kiddos
wow that's gotta be a mind melt
yeah yeah i have one brain cell left um
but so many great clothes now so i kind
of start there
um i actually do not then i do not go to
the papers i go to twitter
um and i scroll and i see kind of like
what articles are popping that's how i
saw the languishing article
and um usually kind of the big scoops of
the night i look at the trending i go
from there
and then you know admittedly i use lots
of curation apps right so i have apple
news
which knows me very well and i'll go and
see what's popping there
i love digital first um outlets like the
daily beast
folks that you know i mean that are
they're not beholden to certain
advertising models
and then i i read yahoo i should
probably say that which is true
i do we have a small team small but
mighty so i like to see kind of what
what they're doing
and then um i i go from there i try not
to read the newsletters and the fact
sheets too much like the playbooks of
the world i love the people who write
them
i know most of them very well but i
worry about getting
something i like to call dc brain where
like
i begin to care about new stories that
like people at yahoo give zero shits
about
do you follow anyone that you disagree
with
for a long time i i think the answer was
no
i didn't either journalistic like
there's my personal politics right which
like that's something completely
different from my
personal accounts but for professionally
i used to
get so angry when i would read
content and i would want to start fights
you know me
i am definitely a bit of a firecracker
yeah
and i am like the little like you know
the little sister
coming in and like beating up the bully
because i don't like when people go
online and say dumb [ __ ] that has bad
consequences
in my older age i realize that's not
always the best
decision and a good way for me to get
capital f fire from wherever i work
and that's the most important thing now
in i think in the last
year or so i've been a lot more um
proactive about following people i both
personally disagree with and not just
following them reading and listening to
their [ __ ]
right like uh i my boyfriend is very big
about
dissenting opinions like being able to
have these conversations
and that has rubbed off on me a lot
recently where i'll listen to
podcasts i'll say this plainly me and
joe rogan probably don't see eye to eye
on lots of things
but he has an impact a lot of people
don't i like to see why
and what snaps and i think britney five
years ago
wouldn't do that or listen to someone
like a provocateur
of the ben shapiro zeitgeist
there's let me there are left-wing
provocateurs they just don't really pop
on my
timeline as much like i don't really
know who those folks are i'm sure
they're in like
the the drags of youtube that i try to
avoid by watching youtube
makeup videos um and
you know he says transphobic things on
his podcast and i get really angry
because i'm not a transphobe i don't
think that's a radical thing for a
journalist to say
they call me old-fashioned right but
it's when those things pop off
especially in the politics realm like
when a politician goes on there or like
a politician is talking about that or he
guest writes playbook
um i like to see why and i feel like
regardless of it making me a better
citizen of the world i think it makes me
a better journalist
and this is a good pin i think a good
way to close to bring up what you said
way at the beginning of this podcast is
that when
reporters talk about let's say trump
voters they do it with such little
compassion
and such assumptions that just don't
exist that those folks
73 million folks are turned off from
reading period
that's on us and i feel like i get an
inch more of compassion or understanding
that i can
approach those stories those profiles
those features
a lot more equitably because those are
just human beings just like biden voters
or just human beings with points of view
and realities in which they struggle
and listening to the media that they
consume
is why i used to watch fox and friends
every morning when i was covering trump
um and why i tried to watch msnbc more
now that biden is president
so that when i approach liberals and
repost democrats
i come with compassion and this is the
key
and andrew and i and try to run our
campaign
this way is the humanity first peace
and i don't know the answer then i think
it's really hard
because listening to somebody that you
really really disagree with
or they've said things that are really
hurtful to you or about people you care
about
um that's hard that is a that is a
growth thing
um but if we don't i think we're going
to end up continuing on the path we're
on now which is we just don't listen to
each other and we just have two
different americas or a million
different americans everybody in their
own little
i don't listen to anybody bubble um so
look i will say this i appreciate you
i'll never forget we were i think we
were in the middle of nowhere iowa and
you
like um and we got to know you and your
team and
or you got to know our team too and it
was um
just you're one of the good ones um
and i thank you for being objective and
let's call this fighting
the good fight um and thank you for
coming on and um letting me
you know ask dumb questions and say dumb
things and have you uh either put me in
my place or
or foster a fascinating conversation so
thank you you're a superstar
glad you joined brittany anytime there
are no dumb questions thank you for
letting me get into more good trouble
you